it's Thursday it's choker Cup finals day
this is like the grand finals I'll be
playing Alexa quiet no no no Alexa
actually no I don't want to get dmca
Alexa stop playing fall out boy good job
making green tea so I have I have nice
green loose leaf tea I also have coffee
iced coffee trigger Joe's Trader Joe's
coconut coffee cold brew the stream is
not sponsored by Trader Joe's but it is
sponsored by choker thanks to choker for
for organizing this event I've I've gone
here by winning the the first three
matches this is the final match if
you're new here feel free to say hi in
the chat and and welcome this is not a
usual this is not a typical stream this
is um this game is a combination of
chess and poker
I've been streaming actually the last
couple Thursday's didn't have a match
the Saatchi the smash got postponed
because Hikaru was doing so well in the
chests full masters this was originally
scheduled for I think late June so yeah
people were asking me like what I've
done to prepare like I tried getting
sleep but then I couldn't sleep but then
I finally slept boulogne for like I do
math maybe six seven hours but I have
okay so I have coffee the coffee is to
wake me up Trader Joe's coffee but I
also have tea at ease to calm me down
so I'll have like a nice nice balance
I'm sure a lot of people in the chat
have never lost Hikaru I've lost I've
akaru at least 50 times on chess calm
probably a bunch of times on ICC I met a
karo in 2011 we played somehow I found
myself playing over the word like
Blitzen bullet with him for several
hours and he beat me at least 30 games
in a row there I did beat Hikaru once in
a 15 minute rapid game on ICC in like I
think it was 2010 he's one of the best
days of my life
oh thanks for the bits hardcore Stan I
mean to say the something something
something wait when did that happen well
it happened a while ago or does it
happen right now
I don't know also chest BAE what's up
Jess BAE
thanks for being here oh except I assume
that's akaru do we start
o begin so oh okay I think we're
starting Hartley okay I sent the the
request ok coffee to wake up and then
tea to calm down I'm crossing my fingers
for no no technical issues also crossing
my fingers for for good cards let me
move them like ok all right focus time
focus time there's up rook oh that's a
good hand that's been raised so blinds
increase by 500
so I'm white which is a slight advantage
already yeah this is a better than
average hand yeah I don't know I'm
nervous but thanks for that the dad-e
bits he raises I think I just want to
shove he probably has a queen but I
wanna i want to just stretch the
variance in this match
yeah okay so he's gonna call Seawind
have raised he probably is like queen
pawn yeah mmm Oh can I get a queen ah if
I got a queen that would have promoted
the pawn to a queen okay so both
hyper-aggressive let's place a pawn
enough three I guess what's the value
here seventeen so it's about average
there's someone who sent me the stats
like some some better stats and while I
had originally calculated before this
match which I tried to memorize okay so
I want to conserve time because he's the
best blitz player in the world
probably the best bullet player in the
world don't tell Magnus that though good
move let's keep trying to poke and prod
he definitely has a queen which is
terrifying but I I oh he also didn't
place up on there oh he probably has me
beat ouch okay I have this tricky move
oh that gives up rook let's actually
play some knight first and then
depending what he places next I'll
either either have the threat of rook h8
or I'll have the threat of Bishop takes
b8 he has a oh yes oh oh so he has a
queen if he has demoted pawn he almost
definitely has a queen which means if I
place a bishop here he places a rook on
h8 hmm I'm probably just oh wait all the
thing the things blocking my thing
I think I'll place a bishop on c2
[Music]
but if he is okay if he doesn't have her
oh he's either has Rooker Queen because
I was demoted pong guy I don't want to
spend so much time if he has a queen on
beat it has a rook then I'm better
oh here's a queen what bah
I'm just losing I could we take a
queenside castle or I could spy Chuck
let's spy Chuck uh this is a really bad
it's Queen G 3 is coming Queens like
castles terrible some wait how bad is
this this is really bad I have to get
stalemated somehow I'm gonna lose this
first clash oh no III doesn't work this
move
no nothing works was Queen d4 is like
Forks everything rotates before stopping
nothing works
oh I have a tricky idea very tricky rook
G 1 if he plays Queen Queen d4 I play
King here and if he takes my Bishop
please take my bishop then I have work
h8 and I win everything draw let's
repeat let's repeat please mmm so this
Queen covers h8 this is really bad I was
a smooth I just want him to plunger
let's yeah let's play Knight b3 please
take my bishop
oh that's just winning that's just
winning I'll let him choke me me oh I
was rough that was the first clash too I
guess I have to update the score yeah
maybe I shouldn't have me I should have
folded after he he bets such a big thing
I was just trying to push the variants
but ok so I think we wait like a minute
right Alexis I saw the timer for a
minute Alexis at the timer alright
yeah I mean I'm using an Android
emulator it's called BlueStacks it's
free to download allows me to play
mobile games on the desktop because
usually in the mobile app you don't
really have them house to use so okay
trying to recover its first of four
clashes I don't know if I mentioned that
but okay there's time to recover maybe I
should try and I'll play him in the
poker face rather than this is average I
think all Ming raised if he shot oh yeah
Elmen raised if he bets big that I just
fold if he calls and I'm fine oh thank
you
okay so he calls so he probably has like
um gisun hand or like average hand thank
you the bomb diggity for something he
checks so I couldn't I could keep I
don't know I'll check back Easy's see
what the next card is it was actually a
below average hand um I might play like
this when I'm really strong to try and
like trap him later if I'm honest
obviously really weak here okay
well have I don't think he's so strong
you there but I mean a 1k bet I have to
call like doesn't make sense to fold
that so I'm gonna go for my default
setup f3g for Bishop on f2 and then
rooks probably in the corners
I'll play g4 I was watching him play a
bit earlier I know he looks to put his
pawns close to his King let's keep a
time advantage interesting
I don't think he has a queen cuz he bet
so small unless he was like trying to
Bay me to raise okay so I could plus or
put a and if he has a rook then Bishop
here it doesn't really do much mm-hmm
I'm assuming he has a row cuz he was a
queen I'm just being let's um let's put
a bishop here if he has a rook then it's
just equal and then we're just gonna try
and flag each other he has a queen what
is a queen what is this at least I
didn't go all the way in though as I was
thinking about like trying to bluff him
out so what's my plan takes my plans to
build a fortress and to flag him despite
being down time I'll see his endgame
technique actually no okay here's my I
have an actual plan my plans to give
away okay let's go g5
no actually it's checks by check time my
plan is to stock all the pawns put my
work on f2 and then get still needed oh
he's just gonna make a queen though
let's try and pawn storm
[Music]
oh no my rook my rook i blundered a rook
please take it
please primo please remove please yes
bro a trap let's go let's go that was
the whole plan how's the whole plan I
can't believe that worked
I thought I thought he knew about that I
mean it was my only chance
oh that's so nice
I was so nice someone clip it someone
clip it uh let's wait I'm so flustered
but he's probably more flustered I have
to duty to calm down
yeah hands are shaking he raises I don't
like this hand yeah to minors yeah let's
fold Oh deep breath deep breath okay so
he has a small chip lead blinds are
increasing I'm white here which means I
but first if I have any good hand all
probably memories blah blah blah let's
fold yeah I don't want to mess with that
I'm accepting a chip deficit oh I see
the chat reacting oh the chat is so nice
look at the chat look look
oh the chat is so nice okay let's focus
Oh Queen okay this is what I was waiting
for him so this is like a a top top 2%
oh he folds oh that's so sad but good
good play oh thanks for gifting subs air
engine tuning appreciate that 50 emotes
shared gifting to the fucsia and so many
other people and pawn masoor and yeah
too many names sorry I do appreciate it
Oh coupons so this is a very volatile
hand it's like it's like Bitcoin let's
let's call I think if if he bets
anything I'll just shove and then I roll
my dice this is actually like I think oh
he checks okay your son I'm fine with
that too oh so I wait let's do math yeah
I have a 60% chance of getting a queen
yeah so I mean this is great to just
check check okay this is one of the
worst hands if I got a pawn bishop or
queen or at pottered bishop would have
promoted to a queen so if he bets
anything I just give up if he checks and
we play chess and I probably lose so I
lose regardless yeah I don't I mean even
even if like he has a single rook he's
he's winning so I have a chip deficits
but I'm one double up away from doubling
up thanks everyone
Oh Eric bruising with Assad oh that's a
funny name similar to brotas okay let's
call this oh I'm puck committed let's
try and Bluff him anyway I probably
should it tells him that I'm
insufficient funds to continue what oh
that's kind of sad I wanted to to play
with the Queen
okay well blinds are increasing at a
rapid pace
so really good just comes down to who
gets better cards I think oh no it's 2 K
the next line will be 2 and 1/2 K it's
still playable I'm small blind and I'm
oh I didn't know that was possible let's
just shove
rolling the dice and gaining that's
iceless hey let's go
I got a queen and a pond and a night
okay so this is about an average this is
a value of 19
let's move quickly always have to think
worst case scenario well thanks for
studying Oh the bruising I preme I can't
remove placement but I know what I'm
gonna do rook will probably be on each
one nine nine f2 so like worst case
scenario all just castle and my king
will be safe best-case scenario I'll be
like up a queen
hopefully Bishop on a fades oh he's he's
being what's the word for predicting the
future he's predicting the future that
I'm gonna put a rook here
so he's just blocking potential checks
so maybe I'll put a rook on a one yeah
we're kind anyone
and then Queen on c2 maybe because if
you put something on the even the Queen
here and the knights always controlling
the square if he has a queen if he has a
queen that I'm worst
please don't have a queen so I'm
threatening the bishop I'm also
threatening a queen g6 check if he's a
queen that's gonna be a fight oh wow
okay so let's do this um probably King
f1 95 expected Queen c3 decent move play
rook could be one so I have 20 second
lead I don't want to give that up even
though that's gonna be tough
right there there have to activate the
night no I have Queen I five actually
it's a nifty move so tying down the
night to the famine Bishop also maybe
ideas a queen a five in the future but I
wanna play 94 could be nice
how did King G to as well
oh he's nifty as well finding my pawn I
have this move for in Queen AIDS
let's play rock Teavana all about time
probably Kingi - next don't want to
blunder anything I don't wanna boat s
gambit oh and I f4 oh he's actually
threatening to win my queen
so let's defend with uh I was a good
move defend with a knight oh he's so
wait what oh that's probably yeah it's
probably good it's not the end of the
world even though it is 2020
okay I just want to trade and draw how
do i trade and draw it's two bishops are
gonna be so annoying f4
no it's the king you King g3 preparing
on for how that because the bishops
always tied down yeah now for now wait
how am i down on time
Oh g5 incoming maybe let's play rook
here threatening or k7 hmm I feel like
I'm gonna get dirty flagged unless I can
build a fortress
I can build a fortress oh wait I was
about to play rook eight have been
really bad let's later okay seven rookie
aid would be met with Bishop e7 the
ultimate fee and cadeaux fork I have to
play this move it feels like I should
have a fortress
all I'm gonna lose upon know is it still
a fortress I don't know
yeah he's like born to play these
positions it's so annoying because he's
gonna make a bazillion moves or he's
gonna prepare d5 well he's allowing this
move
so maybe my keen can get in I just want
to simplify
now I'm gonna get dirty flags once I'm
tricky about it
well what oh he's tricky to play let's
move
okay I have to steal me myself
aha I flagged yeah yeah at least time
for free-moving
well there goes my my second clash hopes
hmm Rosen is a nice giri of stalemates
miss tell me it is a nice giri of chess
okay so I'm down 0 to 2 I'm fighting
already got my my special moments
clippable moments all I want to do is
like win one clash
thanks for the bits this is not even
yeah I'm not even worth calling that's
like the worst hand and it's early so I
can afford to be a bit tighter than
usual so I'm black I'll be the big blind
ah another bad hand but I'm big line so
action is on him if he if he raises I
would fold if he checks I check and he's
give me a screen or fishes okay oh so
this is interesting
so if I get a queen the pawn gets
promoted to another Queen so I'm gonna
check play it off that I'm weak he's
probably gonna win race to try and just
have some fold equity like if he's
strong here then yeah like human races
so I I call and then hope for a queen
and then I'm basically trapping him I
have a rook okay so it's an average hand
actually actions on him luke'll s0 for
thanks for subbing yeah I don't know
should I Bluff him he's probably not too
strong but okay let's splits play chess
okay so I'm black
so I have to play save pawn on g3 what
oh so he's gonna put a bishop on and
plan enough to and Bishop on g2 I know
his strategy so he might have a rook to
place on each one so I'll put an island
on a satin probably wait what
oh here's probably two bishops I don't
understand what he's doing let's put the
bishop here so when the bishop goes on
c2 he's threatening vision of g6 and
Bishop a4 I can put a put something here
actually hmm I don't know what to do
the knight on g7 just be safe Knight was
a very good protector of the King he's
playing very weirdly if he has a queen
I'm busted I might as well threaten meat
right I'm threatening mate in one
please don't see it Oh white moves first
though so he'll probably see it what
he's white oh he's gonna queenside
castle oh that's so funny but does he
know about counseling well it's for the
rook let's test his knowledge the only
move for white is queenside castling
because i'm oh wait what I'm Owen oh I
just lost all my pieces I forgot white
moves first that's so sad I was up at
rook - I thought I was turning meat and
the rook but he takes with Chuck I
should've pulled the rook on e7 Oh No
there he goes all my pieces resign good
thing I didn't shoved Brooke honey seven
would have been just easy win for me
that's what happens when
I'm not calm enough and not awake enough
to drink more coffee
and more tea that was really bad I
should just get like banned for that
since men raise its average Han but if
he has like pawn or pawn minor piece and
I'm hoping for a fold our economy 7
would have been so nice too
oh he folds okay so that was like a semi
bluff I guess so it's actually not it's
not too bad we're about equal yeah we're
about equal no chad is reacting chad is
so disappointed in me this is why i'm an
IM and not a GM yeah that's what
separates separates us too now her car
was really good at spotting undefended
pieces
okay let's um let's just do i bully him
no let's some let's been raised my
huddle I'm in race I know if I was able
to that's smaller there I guess not cuz
big line was all ready to announce Katie
okay so it's not a bad hand to shovel it
so whoever wins this oh this is not a
great hand but I have two bishops what
else what's this good setup of two
bishops Oberlin black
it's it's tough being black because you
always have to respond to threats so at
least I stopped the bishop from doing
things oh he has two bishops - okay I
mean it'd be funny if we have the same
hand it scares me that he didn't place a
pawn please have a pawn
okay let's learn my lesson from the
previous game please have a pawn or
another Knight would be nice it's a
queen
oh gosh oh sorry I'm not gonna put the
rock on b8 I put a rock on 888 I don't
know a d8 so the goal is to sack
everything and stalemate myself again
okay
this move is explosive having hard time
moving
I don't know what to do okay I'm gonna
try the same trap just take all my pawns
take all of them
oh they can't play I have to move I
wreck far away he has a night that
changes things
yeah let's I don't want to get choked me
that
oh don't resign okay I guess I guess it
wants me to get choked mated oh so I
lost I lost zero zero two three but it's
not over we play we play one more Alexis
at the timer for 100 seconds Oh bother
night Patrick oh oh I'm so sorry there's
a 1 minute delay alot so stop it where'd
you buy coconut coffee Trader Joe's it
says it says Trader Joe's ok ok let's
focus
oh thank you how this moral support bits
so you bouts first right yeah he bets
first he calls I'll check
this is this is like the worst for cart
hand I could fold but no well let's
check if he backs I fold
yeah no way Jose
consolation Oh the consolation bits
thanks so much
okay so blinds increase and whites are
the first big line is 1.5 k okay I think
what I'll do I'm gonna slow play this
I'm gonna call I'm gonna trap him cuz I
haven't tried to trap him once
like checks okay good call or good good
check let's see what he's up to
that's mean that this is just the
correct play 1/2 haha thanks not a
looser Panda
Wow he raises so do I just shove let's
wait
let's raise just enough so I can make
the next big blind if something where it
happens yeah he goes okay so of course I
have to call rook okay rook was the best
card cuz Queen would have gotten demoted
to a pawn because I have a queen it's
likely that he doesn't have a queen oh
let's put a put a pawn on a3 question is
where to put the bishops okay I'm white
so I can be the one making threats and I
can be less scared about plundering
things let's put her work on each one if
he has a minor piece who's gonna put it
on on a fate like or Bishop I guess a
pawn interesting I'll put the bishop
here so threatening some idea Bishop a4
so this means I have to put the next
Bishop on a dark square so very possibly
leave he puts a bishop on g7 I put a
bishop on b2 and Queen on a1 and then
that's probably winning also thanks for
that I appreciate that
let's focus I'm probably gonna commit my
bishop
I'm a bishop here
I have to assume okay I always have to
assume worst case scenario if he has a
queen oh wow
I'll put the Queen on you B - okay so if
you're the queen I I'm guaranteed rookie
shades I also have calcium potential be
nice if he has like a minor piece hmm
that's interesting okay so check trying
to calculate the win it's not so simple
though Queen B 5 it's really not simple
I have Queen yeah let's try I don't want
to waste so much time and go with this
and then visit a4
hmm Queens III maybe I'm queen g4 as
well let's try let's try this
where's my win it's so close to winning
Queen Chuck
we have no time to think though okay
Bishop some kind of Bishop move maybe
Queens III King f19 threatening Queen d7
there's got to be some meat there I have
to win this - I'm threatening Queen b6
as well Queen there wait this should be
sixes oh it's almost working wait a
minute
- try this and then castling rook b1
so both bishops are hanging but if he
takes either Bishop rook e1 I think just
wins Oh
it's tricky move mmm I don't know what
to do let's take a pawn oh wow I'm sold
on time the desert g6 is coming
remove I have to I have to take a draw
cuz I'm gonna flag otherwise he's gonna
play rugby - oh what a dirty or work a -
yes straw yes
clutch repetition I should have I should
have won I've moved way too slowly and
he was very slippery
it was trying it like trying to choke
made his King was like trying to catch
like a pig doused in oil all right
oh I have a queen okay oh good hand will
still play it actually blinds are
increasing yeah if I breeze there's a
chance he actually folds
let's check try and come across as weak
it's still a good hand
it's about TJ okay so based on his
bedding I'm likely I'm likely stronger
than him
yeah let's what's bad I'll try and make
it seem like a bluff okay I mean wasn't
really a bluff
I was probably good fold so I definitely
have a better hand than him which means
in hindsight maybe I shouldn't think
that our men raised I don't know but
look at I have a six point or sixty a
chip advantage I have the worst possible
starting hand I don't want to mess with
it
[Music]
okay so blinds are cool this is nice oh
this is like the best so this is a hand
that could very much slow play please
just shove me she shoves yes okay so I
mean he could still get lucky but
beautiful Oh give me a night okay night
would have made the pawn promote to a
queen and this is like still one of the
best hands alright
so probably bishops on he has a demoted
pawn probably means he has a queen I'll
probably hide my King on on f8 Bishop
there's one g7 I'll put like most likely
queen and rook on the Queen side even in
something like this so worst case
scenario is Queen Anne and rook and
would be oh wow he is a knight oh he has
a really bad hand unless he has a queen
coming wait no he placed his final piece
I'm just winning I'll play Queen on b8
yeah it's just over I wouldn't be
surprised if he resigns here okay he's
gonna fight let's put her rook in his
face and put a bishop the ultimate pin
and win and put the Queen dude
everything everything is pinned and
attacked oh he got one spycheck this
feels so good
I have to savor the enjoyment
okay
louder made time please don't disconnect
please don't disconnect yes okay
not everyday you can choke mate Hikaru
Nakamura I won my first class let's go
Alexis are the timer for 100 seconds but
kind of at this point I guess I can
relax because this is my one goal was to
choke me Hikaru and then yeah everything
after this is just icing on the cake oh
thanks chat Oh Charlies reacting
let's show chat look look it's chat
let's go meet school yeah okay Hari
Krishna with 500 bits thanks so much
Oh Alexa stop it motivation bits Alexa
quiet oh I see why move on let's ban
robots and move on okay I Penghu bots so
I'll stop spreading lies okay yeah let's
not mess with this it's early so I think
the strategy I should have realized this
beforehand I just want to get to a point
where the blinds increased so much or I
still have enough chips to play with
[Music]
ooh okay this is actually so someone
sent me the stats on this specific hand
pong pong is actually better than minor
piece even slightly better than rook
pawn just cuz all because this can
happen yeah I think I'm gonna slow play
I'll see I'll see where he's at sweetie
butts I'm going to so I forgot another
pawn that makes another Queen I'm gonna
call trying to come across this week I
got a bishop still a better-than-average
hand let's go Eric let's go
yeah he checks so I want to make I'm
probably better here I want to make a
sizable bet that's about half the pot so
if he if he calls and we play chess
there's still enough fur for one more
one more betting face okay he is white I
might want to go with d65 yeah
especially with pawn in f3 it's likely
he'll put the bishop on f2 so the pawn
on c5 will block the bishop
oh he put some night there I'll still
complete the pawn chain someone said
before the match that they would sub if
they if I win Connect four I won connect
three rookie I'll put a rook you could
put a bishop on a - it's actually put a
bishop on f7 first so this is the
general chess principle when you have
pawns on York's worries you want a light
square bishop just a positional rule of
chess
okay so I'm throwing me than one but
he's gonna move first I can't I can't
forget that light moves first
hmm and he has a queen so a queen on h8
would be nifty but probably not
objectively good so the Queen on sb7 oh
yeah that was his final piece so I'm up
I'm not the exchange
oh so I'm better here but Knight sir
Knights are very tricky this won't be
easy
let's try and trade Queens I just I just
miss made in one I was not expecting him
to get me made in one he gave me may
than one I didn't take it choked me than
one rook Ji Won was just mates oh no
it's like it's like he he gave me all
these Christmas presents in the middle
of July I just wasn't expecting it oh
I'm so tilted but let's try and fight
let's try and fight let's try and
penetrate with a queen
not my time he knows he can he can
survive again this is King is so
slippery and this move I have a really
bad feeling I'm about to get forked like
these Knights are so good at forking
I'm so mad at myself
that's okay okay let's not get tilted in
each for check his night is so annoying
so the Queen the Queen defends that you
sat in pawn if he's capable of hanging
Nathan one once
maybe he's capable of hanging Nathan won
again
please see place III so I'll win d5
Knight checks I take it with a queen
[Music]
three six seconds
I just want to simplify and trade Queens
okay let's restrict so the bishop
restricts tonight
very likely we're trading Queens here
he's going out of his way not to trade
Queens look at that sad Queen oh he's
gonna play Queen a one Queen each for
maybe let's try and trade still let's
take with and this move we need you for
coming
mmm-hmm Bishop each three idea that's
annoying
that's not let me move my time my
beautiful time so what's the best
approach here a queasy five
he's 60 al does he have so much time yes
over 60 seconds I just moved I guess I
moved way too so oh he he really rubbed
it in my face there so it's not over so
I made a good betting decision not to
put all the chips in all I need to do is
double up one two three times okay I
have the worst possible to car hands
let's shove because I'm already pot
committed this could be it ooh
give me another give me a pawn oh this
isn't so bad I don't think it was
actually better than it's about average
I guess you have to move way faster and
I also have to spot me than once
okay so he could have anything because I
mean he would have called was anything
[Music]
f2 probably other than Island II to me
queen on be one has the most checking
potential hiding my queen for last hey
I'm up on time this is gonna be a
short-lived time advantage please have a
bishop or another pawn hmm okay this
isn't so bad I should be able to win
this if I can't win this and I don't
deserve to win this but let's try
so first priority's time second priority
is finding Forks this is kind of a fork
he's gonna play rook c2 no oh no it's my
night okay going 496 also e7 is very
weak so I stopped rook d7 this is a fork
hey I force found the night work let's
go oh he's trying to build a fortress oh
that's so nifty so I have to use my keen
somehow we keep my queen and king on
different color squares that way the
Knights let's play Queen h89 takes g4 i
have Queen h5 it's incredible that he's
able to try and survive like this I
think it's gonna last eventually is
gonna be in some zoos long they even
right now I think it's long yeah I was
actually nice looks long cuz I hatch
then they had no moves I mean that move
I win the night and the any key move at
the very least guy kini six
okay so that was a clean
that's probably my cleanest chest phase
but I can't celebrate because I'm still
ooh two nights is probably one of the
worst starting hands because there's
high high probability of of demotion but
if I gather if I get a bishop the pawn
gets promoted to a queen so I do want to
see the next hand or the next uh next
card so question is do I fold this is a
really tough decision I think I fold
because if I don't get a I'm just losing
otherwise my my chances are better in a
better spot that was a good putt by him
so I do have enough chips I'm probably
pot committed something lined I'm one
double-up away from being close to equal
I'm pot committed the same the same hand
okay let's I have to go all in and I'm
hoping for basically a full house what
we call an empress where okay so I want
another Rock please give me or another
if I got another rook the pawn would
have turned into a queen but this is um
okay this is not too hopeful what's the
value of this no this is like one of the
worst okay let's put the Knights
okay I have to enjoy my last my last
chest phase against akaru before wait do
I have any hope if we if we draw here I
have to think best-case scenario it's um
maybe I'll just castle to be extra safe
I'm already already definitely down
material unless yes you have you could
have a queen he has a queen what does
this counseling never too late to castle
never too early to castle all I want to
do is fork okay I'm gonna do this try
and do the same thing that he did oh I'm
in check I was in check
try and do the same thing that he did to
me like build a fortress with the night
in pawns
let's see his is a grandmaster technique
this Knight is a boss because it defends
it defends H 1 and E 2 but he's gonna
he's gonna go for his son oh that's what
he's going for
Oh so please wait how do I sack
everything and get stalemated probably
like this then III take on e3 please
that's all you can still meet because I
have a pawn uh that's it well that's
life sometimes you win and sometimes you
get choked mated that was fun um I hope
people enjoyed that I think that was I
mean I was pretty bug free oh look at
this look at this chat
look at this chat and all these oh I
want to show this pork neck emotes
LeFort my emotes I guess it was one I
thought was many people spamming it was
just one person
yeah so what to do now I guess I want to
thank akaru for the opportunity I want
to thank choker for sponsoring this
whole this whole event this is like like
the culmination of the choker Cup the
final score in terms of clashes was 4 to
1 what were the highlights the
highlights were there's definitely the
the salem a trap and my one choke means
but my brook plunger and missing mate
and one was also I was also unfortunate
so I'm not gonna ban Hikaru oh there's a
copy mode attached to that no Hikaru is
a VIP in this channel and in life